[Applause]
prince louis gets cheeky literally at
thursday's trooping of the color
ceremony
the full royal family was up on a
buckingham palace balcony to take in the
tradition which kicks off queen
elizabeth's platinum jubilee marking her
70 years on the throne
and louis positioned next to his great
gran proves that even royal
four-year-olds are still well
four-year-olds pulling silly face after
silly face as the crowd watches on the
four-year-old had the best facial
expressions as he wildly waved to the
crowd and chatted to his
great-grandmother the queen
and check out this hilarious moment yeah
louis clearly isn't a fan of the loud
aircraft noises
closing his eyes and letting out what
appears to be a scream during the fly
past
meanwhile louie's older brother and
sister prince george and princess
charlotte seem very into the whole thing
pretty much in awe while louis he stays
unimpressed
ahead of the celebration the duke and
duchess of cambridge's kiddos made their
carriage debut greeting onlookers which
provided us with this must-see moment
charlotte taking a break from waving to
the crowd and basically demanding little
louie follow her lead yeah watch
charlotte go into total big sis mode as
she grabs louie's hand and puts it on
his lap
oh and did you catch this recycled
fashion moment louie is wearing the same
adorable sailor suit his dad prince
william wore to the same event back in
1985.
queen elizabeth's platinum jubilee
celebration continues all weekend long
including a full royal family gathering
at friday's service of thanksgiving and
yes harry and megan will be there this
marks the first time the couple returned
to the uk with their children since
stepping down as senior royals and
relocating to california in 2020. she's
traveled here to the uk with
three-year-old archie and the queen's
namesake lilybet her majesty is expected
to meet harry and megan's daughter for
the first time on saturday during lilly
bett's first birthday
and the queen is making it a priority to
get in some quality time with her
granddaughter et's learned she's
actually skipping an event on saturday
to hang with lillabet a source close to
the royal family tells e.t the queen is
delighted she will be meeting the little
one who's actually named after her and
of course she's excited to spend time
with lillabet's big bro archie too
[Music]